it's October 2016 Grand Theft Auto
online is still going strong and it's
about to get a Halloween update I'm Tony
and this is your seasonal GameSpot news
update GTA online Halloween event is all
about the bikes first a new version of
the LCC Sanctus with a wicked skull
ornament is coming to the game a new
lost versus damns multiplayer mode is
also on the way which pits a team of
angels against a team of devils the
day/night cycle shifts every 60 seconds
giving angels a boost in the light and
The Devil's a boost in the dark on top
of that a ton of fan favorite vehicles
like the Roosevelt valor in the Valkyrie
helicopter will be 30% off until
November 7 in celebration of the game's
three-year anniversary
GTA online Halloween update kicks off
Friday October 28th log in between now
and October 31st and Rockstar will give
you a nice 250,000 dollar in-game treat
GTA isn't the only game getting into the
Halloween spirit so head over to
GameSpot to learn more about Destiny's
Festival of the Lost or over watch's new
brawl and for all the spookiest video
game news you're already in the right
place
you